de la atención justamente pasaban a mi
costado y por eso los aplausos los
músicos de la guardia de los ganaderos
recordemos la guardia más antigua del
reino unido- de la que ella era coronel
en jefe que se espera buenos espera que
llegue a eso de las tres de la tarde ese
coche fúnebre a las tres y diez
comenzará una procesión lenta para
recorrer los cinco kilómetros que le
llevan a este paseo que hay a mi derecha
que ustedes ven en imágenes hasta la
puerta del castillo la idea es que todas
las personas que están aquí cerca de
1000 puedan observar el féretro de la
reina de rendirle un último tributo
hasta que llegue al castillo a eso de
las tres y cuarenta la familia real se
unirá a esta procesión del carro fúnebre
y acompañarán a la reina hasta la
capilla de san jorge donde va a tener
lugar ese servicio religioso que va a
haber varios momentos simbólicos uno por
ejemplo cuando se retiren por parte
el joyero de la corona los símbolos de
la realeza esos símbolos o instrumentos
del estado que se le llama están a la
corona imperial del estado el cetro y el
orbe van a ser retirados puestos en el
altar y luego enviados a londres a la
london al bridge sino otro momento
importante es cuando el príncipe carlos
antiguo príncipe carlos me cuesta
decirlo ahora el rey carlos tercero
coloque el estandarte justamente de los
guardias de los granaderos en el ataúd a
de su madre y luego éste va a descender
va a ver también por ejemplo un lamento
por parte del gaitero de la reina y algo
final al hacer la entrega de la
bendición va a estar por parte del
arzobispo de canterbury y se entonará
obviamente el god save the king ese
ataúd va a descender porque esta
ceremonia a la que están invitadas 900
personas quien no estuvieron por cierto
en westminster
sobre se va a realizar sobre el coro de
esta capilla luego este féretro va a
descender a la bóveda y más tarde a las
siete y media de la tarde tendrá lugar
otra ceremonia está así que privada que
no será transmitida por televisión en
que la familia real nada más hará esa
entrada a esa capilla de jorge el sexto
el padre de la reina de este féretro
acompañado en el de su marido el
príncipe felipe